good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the thing about the
chinese government is this is kind of
weird the chinese government almost
never celebrates diversity think about
that american liberals liberals
throughout the west love china it's
justin trudeau's model but china does
not celebrate diversity
in fact and the american media never
says this but it's absolutely true china
is a militarized ethno state it's run
along traditional fascist lines for the
benefit of a specific ethnic group the
han chinese
that's not supposed to be allowed but
they're doing it
so to chinese leaders the concept of
diversity equity and inclusion those
concepts make no sense at all at best
they're bizarre it's one of those
incomprehensible jokes that western
liberals tell the chinese don't get it
at all so when nancy pelosi took off for
taiwan today aboard a u.s military jet
the chinese government did not issue a
statement applauding her remarkable
display of spunky girl power
no one in beijing congratulated nancy
pelosi for breaking glass ceilings is
the very first speaker in history to
identify as a woman no one in china even
mentioned that
instead chinese leaders treated pelosi's
arrival like an invasion air raid siren
sounded in coastal towns in china as her
plane approached when she finally landed
the chinese military announced live fire
exercises in the airspace around taiwan
for the next four days
china's foreign ministry declared that
nancy pelosi's mere presence quote
gravely undermines peace and stability
across the taiwan strait end quote
proving that in asia as at home things
rarely improve when nancy pelosi shows
up
so the question really is why did she go
in the first place that's the real
question and the official line in
washington as always is totally
implausible is that pelosi's trip was
designed to quote reaffirm taiwan's
status as a u.s ally
okay
except the problem is taiwan is not a
u.s ally in fact taiwan may be the only
country in the world the bid
administration believes does not have
the right of self-determination
quote we do not support taiwan's
independence
wait a second they're against democracy
you know if they were for democracy
right they're always throwing democracy
at you turns out they don't mean it not
that you ever thought they did
so the one thing you can be certain of
is that nancy pelosi did not fly all the
way to taiwan to signal that the united
states is going to defend that island
from a chinese invasion we're not going
to do that we're not in a position to do
that even if we wanted to do that
we've already sent too many of our
surface-to-air missiles for example to
ukraine where our oligarch friends are
busy selling them to various dark actors
on the international arms market
so if there's a major war in asia
anytime soon we will not be winning it
every sober person knows that sad but
true
so what's really going on here well on
the internet you may have noticed quite
a bit of speculation some of it
generated by chinese state media that
pelosi went to taiwan to check on
investments that her husband paul made
using insider information he did make
those investments in the su insider
information that's why he's such a
fantastic stock picker worth more than
100 million dollars
in this case paul pelosi bought
semiconductor stock taiwan makes
semiconductors rising tensions in the
region would create more demand for
semiconductors that's the theory
is it true well nancy pelosi is from
baltimore so we would not put anything
past her but it doesn't quite satisfy as
an explanation
that is a long and highly public trip to
take for a relatively small investment
there's got to be something else going
on
what is it
well it is entirely possible that the
most obvious explanation for this
debacle is the right one it's possible
the by demonstration are so completely
incompetent the people who run the white
house are so utterly blinded by their
own arrogance and their ineptitude that
they just don't appreciate or even
understand the implications of what they
are doing
so nancy pelosi got bored of spending
the summer in napa and she wanted to
take a free trip to asia where she could
pretend to be a statesman for a week
girl power
let her go
it's possible that's all the thinking
they did before signing off on pelosi's
trip
here for example in john kirby who
you're supposed to take seriously
proving the point effectively this
morning on fox
the aggressiveness the coercion the
increase in tensions in the last weeks
and months have all come from the
chinese side what we have said
is that there's no reason that this
visit should escalate tensions in any
way whatsoever
oh so there's no reason that this visit
should escalate tensions in any way
whatsoever thanks john kirby for
describing the world as you fervently
wish it was we'd love knowing your views
on perpetual motion machines
now back to reality as we actually find
it
nancy pelosi's trip to taiwan has in
fact dramatically escalated tensions in
the region throughout asia in fact
escalated to more than any single act in
recent memory
so you have to ask yourself for what
how exactly is the united states which
he serves
benefiting from what she's doing is
there an upside here for us
that's one question that people like
john kirby never think to ask they just
assume that china must be bluffing just
another backward third world government
making huffy noises don't have to take
them seriously just like russia well
they say they're going to invade ukraine
if we push ukraine to join nato who
cares what they think
they're a gas station with a government
they're bluffing
that's what arrogance does to you it
blinds you to reality
so the question is is china bluffing
what if they're not
what if in response to pelosi's totally
pointless trip to taiwan the chinese
decide to seize the kingman islands
which are now governed by taiwan and
whose defense we've implicitly and
effectively guaranteed for 75 years
well that could actually happen
the chinese government is already making
the kind of noises you would expect it
to make before doing something like that
here's a selection
ahead of the stop the chinese government
continued to ramp up their warnings
saying it undermines china's sovereignty
and security
we hope u.s officials will clearly
understand the importance and
sensitivity of the issue and how
dangerous it would be if the visit
actually happens the chinese claim
taiwan as their own and there are
concerns beijing could use the visit as
a pretext to ramp up military action in
the area
huh
maybe that's bluffing maybe it's not
but the deeper question is
when's the last time american liberals
built something when is the last time
nancy pelosi or joe biden
or any of these people susan rice
created something worth having hmm
we'll give you a few minutes
never they break things
they show up they make things worse they
move on to the next thing they never
apologize they did in afghanistan they
did it in iraq they did it in ukraine
they did it in syria they did it in
libya are they going to do it now with
china
breaking things in fact if you were
trying to give beijing a pretext to
seize taiwan this is exactly the kind of
trip you would take and what would
happen if beijing seized taiwan will be
humanitarian disaster for the taiwanese
they would lose any semblance of
self-determination democracy would die
so that's bad
but more to the point it would be a
disaster for us
for us because it would make
and this has been the effect of
virtually every policy to come out of
the biodemonstration it would make china
more powerful how powerful is china we
understate their power actually china
already makes 90 of the world's
antibiotics it makes 80 percent of the
world's lithium batteries 96 of the
shipping containers used to transport
goods across the world mostly from china
are made in china
but one thing china does not yet control
is the semiconductor industry at the end
of 2021 china held just four percent of
the global semiconductor market north
america and the asia pacific region are
the dominant players now semiconductors
are not a small thing in fact they're
essential to modern life they're in
everything from brake sensors in your
car to your phone to your computer
they're in everything
and as it happens virtually all advanced
semiconductors are made where are they
made or they're made in taiwan
the taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
company makes 90 of the world's advanced
semiconductors it is by far the world's
largest semiconductor foundry
without the taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company
that would mean companies like apple
qualcomm and many others could not
function
that's a lot of the american economy
last year taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company accounted for more
than half of the total foundry revenue
in the world
so
maybe showing up in taiwan would give
beijing a pretext to invade taiwan and
take over the world's largest
semiconductor foundry
and that puts us in the beta position to
an even greater extent to put it mildly
is that the goal of this trip
could it be that tony blinken and barack
obama and the rest of people who are
actually running the biden
administration without the knowledge of
joe biden who can't remember anything at
this point could it be that all these
people know perfectly well how reckless
this is know perfectly well what the
effects could be and they're doing it
not just in spite of those effects but
because of those effects because
actually at least on some gut level they
want to hasten the end of american
hegemony which is to say the end of the
us as we know it
that would explain why they sent kamala
harris of all people to avert a war on
ukraine knowing full well that kamala
harris would read the notes they wrote
for her and insist that ukraine join
nato and then guarantee that russia
invades ukraine constricts the world's
energy and food markets and makes us
weaker
huh maybe they knew that would happen
maybe they're not that stupid maybe that
would also explain why they sent nancy
pelosi over to taiwan effectively as the
administration's representative even
though nancy pelosi rivals kamal harris
in her inability to form a coherent
thought
now again we alluded this last night but
it's just true because we watch this
stuff we hope you don't hope you have a
real life but if you've seen nancy
pelosi recently since she turned 80 for
example two years ago you know this is
someone who is having a lot of trouble
speaking he was pelosi the briefing back
in november for example
the other thing that we're getting are
we're sending stuff over to the senate
well it's
most of the product that we've done is
except now we we may have had it in the
last day or so and some of what we added
is senate
to the bill like a hearing
bernie doesn't like hearing
excuse me bernie loves hearing
mentioned it doesn't want hearing in the
bill melissa um
so somebody sent orient and then we had
the family medical need we figured if
they're putting things in then we can
put something in
even if manchin doesn't like so um uh
so we are getting some
bird and privilege
i think i think mostly we're getting
privileged scrub because privileged drug
is deadly to a bill convertible
is important
you have to take it out
but
privilege violation can take you out
so at this point august of 2022 taiwan
is the world's great flashpoint it's the
largest power
with an aim it has articulated
repeatedly over almost 80 years to
invade
a neighboring country taiwan so there's
no more delicate place diplomatically on
the globe
so if you're sending that person to calm
tensions or reassure our allies you're
probably not doing what you say you're
doing you may be doing the opposite if
you're trying to provoke your enemies
and terrify your so-called allies you'd
probably pick nancy pelosi as your
representative in taiwan
what is going on here
well if you're wanting to understand the
motive of the people in charge consider
this at the same moment that we are
clearly goading other countries into
conflict with each other and with us
we are meaning that by demonstration is
degrading our ability to participate or
prevail in those wars our defensive
capabilities have never been weaker and
that's not an accident they did it
for example
the central intelligence agency whatever
you think of it we don't think much kind
of important
to our country
certainly well funded here's a recent
recruiting ad from the cia
i'm a woman of color i am a mom
i am a cisgender millennial who's been
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder
i am intersectional but my existence is
not a box checking exercise i am a
walking declaration a woman whose
inflection does not rise at the end of
her sentences suggesting that a question
has been asked i used to struggle with
imposter syndrome but at 36 i refuse to
internalize misguided patriarchal ideas
of what a woman can or should
be oh you're intersectional with a
generalized anxiety disorder come work
in a critical federal agency
so if you're running an ad like that not
only are you not serious you are trying
to degrade and hurt
the ability of the united states to
defend itself to perpetuate itself
to remain the united states for our
grandchildren that's exactly what let's
stop lying about this exactly what
you're doing it's not just happening at
cia
nothing joe biden has done in the last
year and a half has made our armed
forces better prepared to fight wars
instead it has been one calculated
humiliation after another for the us
armed forces vax mandates anti-white
ideology sex changes drag shows
whatever is necessary to telegraph to
the united states military you are
worthless you are defending a country
that does not deserve to be defended
your traditions are disgusting
you're terrible that's the message
here's the latest the va has decided to
desecrate military seminar cemeteries
that'd be america's last remaining
national shrine or military cemeteries
desecrated with industrial wind turbines
one just went up any massachusetts
national cemetery
so take three steps back they are
starting more wars while simultaneously
making it harder for the united states
to fight and prevail in those wars
a spokesperson for the chinese foreign
ministry said this morning that their
army will quote never sit by either well
you know what we have an army too and
would take strong
either don't tell our leaders where they
can go and where they can't defend i
salute nancy pelosi for going there for
sending a message uh that taiwan is an
ally and and just as we won't support
taiwan's independence uh
and breaking away from this one china
policy
we will not stand idly by
if if
mainland china decides to invade taiwan
more childish posturing from people who
have no idea what they're talking about
and no skin in the game whatsoever
the truth is we're not in a position to
prosecute a successful war against china
we should be we should have been making
defensive strategic moves for the past
20 years onshoring critical
manufacturing
building up a strong military and yes a
strong cia not degrading them with
identity politics and other pointless
lunacy that detracts from the mission
which is to protect the united states
but that's exactly what we've done
republicans in congress have allowed it
to happen oh more funding for you
so whatever the motive here is the
effect is absolutely predictable as with
afghanistan and ukraine and covet and
pick nine other disasters when we're
watching right now finally ends the u.s
is likely to be weaker and china is
likely to be stronger
so what does this mean it means the
beginning of the end of american
influence in asia influence that we paid
for with blood and that's not an
overstatement more than half a million
american servicemen were killed or
wounded the pacific theater in the
second world war and in korea a few
years after that and as a result of
their sacrifice and wise diplomacy
countries like japan and south korea and
singapore in the philippines have all
been in our orbit the western orbit
america's orbit for most of the last
century and that's been a good thing for
all involved not perfect but better than
the alternative but we're about to see
the alternative thanks to whatever the
motive
the lunacy of people like pelosi and
biden
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight